you know that friend you had in high
school
who was way cooler than you were
attractive got all the attention from
everyone
hello that pressure is very real and i
know that there are people who like are
were obsessed with she-hulk as like a
comic you know for since the beginning
there has been critique that like her
body is not muscular and to me i kind of
find that to be an interesting
conversation to have too
jen do your thing god i really like this
outfit so much of her is about the way
people look at her differently depending
on which body she's presenting at that
time jen walters is received very
differently than she hulk is but the
actress is happy there's room to make
this character her own i think what's so
cool about these comic book characters
and you see it throughout the comics
you know she-hulk physically looks
different in different comics depending
on the artist and she's put in scenarios
that are sometimes more dramatic or more
comedic and there's like an ability to
stretch and like explore a character
wow jesus what the hell man still in
control no overwhelming feelings of rage
no a normal amount of rage you do revert
back to gen 4 when you sleep was the air
horn really necessary for comedy
absolutely for her to be kind of placed
in today
and to sort of be relating to things
that are happening today feels
feels like an important part of her
character who's your best friend
nikki
spandex spandex is your best friend
[Music]